welcome to the show friends neighbors
colleagues associates today we're going
to talk about what I call the
criminalization of childhood both the
criminalization and the medicalization
of childhood which is happening in our
school system we'll discuss that also
I'm excited today to be cancelling
Elizabeth Warren finally I'll explain
why and we'll go over a five headline
several of them coronavirus related fun
times as always and in the new segment
we're also going to talk about a bill
that just passed making lynching illegal
on the federal level but wasn't it
illegal already everywhere yes it was
but which of course is why this bill
though it sounds like something that
nobody could possibly oppose there are
actually very good reasons to oppose it
and I'll explain that as well all of
that coming up first a word from ring
you know this isn't about being paranoid
or anything like that but it is about
protecting yourself and the reality is
you never know when a break-in could
occur and if you live in in high crime
areas then you know that there's an that
that elevated risk but even if you don't
even if you live out and you know out in
the middle of nowhere kind of like I do
still it could it could always happen
which is why you want to protect
yourself rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer make people safer
make home safer you might already know
about their smart video doorbells and
cameras that protect millions of people
everywhere well ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor whether a surprise
visitor you want or don't want you're
gonna get an alert you'll be able to see
you can even interact with that person
from anywhere in the world you know my
that's what I found to be so great about
ring is both the the convenience of it
but also what we're talking about just
the security of knowing that you have
your eyes on everything as a subscriber
you have a special offer on a ring
welcome kit available right now at ring
comm slash Walsh
that's ring comm slash Walsh the kit
includes a video doorbell and chime Pro
which is just what you need to get a
ring of security started around your
house today
go to ring.com slash Walsh again that's
ring.com slash Walsh
okay so criminalization of childhood
footage was released this week showing a
police officer in Orlando walking into
an elementary school and arresting a
six-year-old girl the child accused of
having a tantrum and hitting her
teachers had her hands zip-tied and was
put in the back of a squad car
as she was crying and trembling with
fear and and pleading to be given
another chance put a squad car taken to
jail in fact let me play for you the
footage right now this is the footage of
the actual arrest as it happens I think
there's a an important point to note
here as you're watching this that it's
not like the police came in and the the
young girl was in the middle of a
hysterical freak out and she was hitting
people know by this point she had calmed
down she was just sitting there and then
they come in and cuff her so watch this
[Music]
[Music]
that you know the expression makes my
blood boil
well that when I watch it something like
that I I can feel I think I can
literally feel my blood boiling within
me and it just makes me very angry maybe
part of the part of the reason might be
that I have a six-year-old daughter
myself and the idea that she could be
arrested for anything at all is is first
of all simply ludicrous okay if you know
anything about six-year-olds if you've
ever met one then you you should
understand how ridiculous this is and my
blood boil is even more because as I've
been talking about this issue I wrote
something about it yesterday we're
talking about it on social media a fair
number of people what maybe it won't
surprise you defending the police
officer now as we'll talk about in a
minute even his own Police Department
doesn't defend him they fired him for
this and rightfully so but there are
still people who I think are when it
comes down to it such such bootlickers
of the state it refused to criticize
police officers for any reason
whatsoever no matter what they do that
they'll even defend this which his own
bosses would not defend his police chief
came out and was horrified by it and yet
there are people that will see it yeah I
saw some comments like teach that
spoiled brat a lesson those kind of
comments she's six you animal
you Beast I mean she's six do you
understand what that means
now the courageous cop valiantly
defending society from ill-tempered
first-graders can be heard later on in
the body cam footage bragging about the
fact that that that this this six year
old that he arrested breaks his record
for the youngest child that he's that
he's ever arrested there's no sense of
seriousness here at all
just callous indifference for the child
and to him it seems like it's just all a
big all a big joke watch watch this
she's eight you know she she's six now
she had broken the record absolutely no
concern for from this guy about the
trauma that the child suffered and that
is trauma okay yes the word trauma is
way overused college kids encountering
opinions they don't like say they're
traumatized
that's not trauma doing this to a child
that that is actually literally
traumatic now keep in mind you know he
says he arrested a seven-year-old what
was the reason he gave you say he
arrested the seven-year-old because the
seven-year-old I guess stole something
and didn't think it was serious and
that's why he was arrested so he was
teaching him a lesson
yeah well of course he didn't think it
was serious he's seven seven year olds
don't think anything is serious because
they're seven now this girl was taken to
a detention center where her mug shot
was taken don't you imagine that a mug
shot of a six-year-old girl and she was
officially brought up on charges of
criminal assault for hitting somebody
wanna read and reiterate again
six-year-old girl taken to a jail given
a mug shot
brought up on charges of criminal
assault to emphasize for the fifth time
she's six now we should mention that
this officer Dennis Turner apparently
has a history of being a power drunk
scumbag he was investigated back in 2015
for tasing a man five times even though
the guy wasn't actively resisting just
kept tasing him anyway
yeah yeah why not ma'am eyes will keep
doing it and reportedly he the officer
that is was also arrested himself back
in 1998 for aggravated assault of a
child so maybe you have some kind of
problem with children I'm not sure now
Turner as I said has been fired for his
actions at the school but serious
questions remain for for instance how
did a callous incompetent like this guy
who's twice been put under investigation
by his own department for abuse of force
how did he end up as a resource officer
at an elementary school and more broadly
is it really a good idea to criminalize
childhood misbehavior that's the
fundamental question I want to ask this
may be an extreme example of it but
grade schools all across the country
have increasingly been treating
discipline problems as legal infractions
this is a trend that we are seeing with
increasing regularity kids who lack
emotional maturity not because there's
something wrong with them but because
their kids now face the possibility of a
criminal record for behavior that you
know for our parents and grandparents
would have simply landed them in
detention but now we say no not
detention the detention center the
criminalization of schoolyard bullying
is another example there are many states
across the country that have passed
actual laws against bullying that that
effect even elementary schools so a
third grader who's bullying another
third grader could be breaking the law
now and we're gonna get the courts
involved so what you saw the footage
there is extreme but
not that extreme here's the issue though
children especially in the elementary
school ages are not reasonable creatures
they do not possess the psychological
capacity to control themselves their
actions to express their their emotions
the way that we can so that's why a
six-year-old might freak out and cry in
all these things it's because they just
they don't have the wherewithal they
don't have the the the capacity to
express themselves yet I mean they have
some capacity for it but not a fully
developed capacity this again is not
their fault it's just a natural facet of
childhood we were all unreasonable and
emotional children once all of us were
many of us still are now does this mean
that misbehavior disrespect etc should
be tolerated or that disruptive children
should be given free rein to do whatever
they want no of course not but there's
see to me it seems like there's a lot of
real estate in between letting a kid do
whatever they want and arresting them
and throwing them in jail it seems like
there's a lot of room in between that we
could explore seems to me now if an
adult hits another adult that's assault
when a six-year-old hits somebody it's
not a assault anymore then it's it's
it's theft it's legal theft if a toddler
steals a Barbie doll from her daycare
center does anyone think I mean if we're
putting six-year-olds in jail for
hitting somebody then is it that crazy
to put a three or four year old in jail
for stealing a Barbie doll from the
daycare center bring him up on criminal
charges of theft there's only a two or
three year difference between the three
or four year old and six year old but
this is a matter of culpability and we
used to understand that children have
very
little of that very little culpability
that is in fact a child's culpability is
so negligible that even if that girl
even if she killed somebody
okay let's I mean let's take the
absolute worst case scenario we could
possibly imagine where this girl rather
than slapping somebody which by the way
there was no no one went to the hospital
there was no injuries sustained okay if
you mean if you're seriously injured by
getting slapped by a six-year-old girl
then you're like mr. mr. glass and
unbreakable it's it's uh that would be
quite impressive so there's no injuries
but let's just say absolute worst case
scenario you could ever imagine
six-year-old girl somehow cuz their
hands on a gun shoot somebody on purpose
even then I would say it would be crazy
to throw her in jail and charged her
with a crime why is that because if a
six-year-old girl is doing something
like that
it is 100% guaranteed that her mind has
been warped by severe severe physical
emotional abuse at home and now she
quite literally cannot control herself
and doesn't know what she's doing that's
a guarantee if you have a kid doing that
then you know that for a fact and in
fact even if she hasn't been abused
six-year-olds still don't know it really
know what they're doing and and aren't
actually capable of intentionally
killing someone the way that we can
because they don't really understand
what death is they don't understand the
permanence of death so they couldn't
possibly appreciate what it actually
means to kill somebody the way that you
are I can't so a six-year-old kills
someone even in that case yeah you might
have to take them to a facility to
protect themselves and others but the
the goal there would be to treat them to
treat the very severe psychological and
emotional problems that they they
clearly have the goal is not to put them
in a jumpsuit and and throw them in the
clink that's not what we do with
six-year-olds or at least we didn't used
to but we're not just criminalizing
childhood see this this issue goes
beyond it goes even deeper than that
where childhood is not criminalized it's
medical
and that's why over seven million
children in this country have been
placed on psychiatric medication for
mental disorders 7 million children you
actually think there are 7 million
children in this country that are
mentally ill 7 million kids mentally ill
well we know that's not the case because
half of those cases of kids that are on
psychiatric drugs have a quote unquote
ADHD all-in-all about 6 million children
over half of them under the age of 11
have been diagnosed with this this
phantom disorder of ADHD now as I've
argued extensively elsewhere and I won't
get into the whole spiel again but the
ADHD diagnosis turns normal childhood
behavior into symptoms of mental illness
now it may be true that these behaviors
a child who fidgets a lot can't pay
attention has a lot of energy you know
can't can't do busy work and all that
maybe maybe inconvenient it may be
difficult to deal with but that doesn't
mean that it's a symptom of a disorder
doesn't mean that the child is mentally
ill if the school system's proper
functioning depends on drugging millions
of kids if you're telling me that's the
only way that this will work is if we
drug these kids that I would say it's
the system that's disordered not the
kids the sickness is not in our kids but
in our attitude towards them and our
expectations of them if millions of
nine-year-old boys have have a lot of
trouble and seem incapable of sitting at
their desk for eight hours a day
performing busy work and regurgitating
information onto scantron sheets well
then maybe we should consider the
possibility that this is not a very good
way of educating nine-year-old boys or
we could keep shoving drugs in their
face or sending them to jail until they
until they shape up you know that's one
option
now our children are not mentally
disordered they aren't criminals and
this generation of children not very
different from any other generation
before them I know we'd like to say Oh
kids today are so much worse back in my
day we didn't act this way well you know
what if you go back through history
literally every single generation of
adults has said that about the current
generation of kids their their their
contemporary generation because maybe we
should consider the possibility that
this whole thing back in my day people
didn't do this maybe we should consider
the possibility that this is an illusion
it's not actually like that that
actually back in your day when you were
a kid you were doing the same stuff you
just don't remember it now or you have a
romantic view of your own behavior as a
kid no you were a little brat too it's
just that you could be a little brat
without getting drugs shoved in your
mouth or have the possibility of getting
your mug shot taken at the age of six
down at the juvenile detention center no
see you you you were given space to be a
kid you you were allowed to make the
mistake of acting your age when you were
a child you were allowed to do that
but not now our kids today we don't let
them I admit here's here's the here's
the thing and I I say this again because
any time I talk about this kind of thing
what I'm told is well what do you expect
the schools to do what what can they do
this is the only choice they have well
if that's the case then tear down the
system then tear down the entire city
this system is broken fundamentally and
it needs to be destroyed
completely and rebuilt from the ground
up if you're telling me this is the only
way the system works is to drugged kids
to criminalize them to throw them in
jail to arrest them to give them
criminal records to treat the
for mental illnesses to treat them like
they're crazy like they're psychotic
just because they're normal kids if
you're telling me that's the only way
that the system can function then there
are serious serious problems with the
system and what I would say is if we
can't tear down the entire system which
is what I would like to see happen
because I think our entire way of
educating kids our entire approach is
completely wrong in my view but if we
can't do that then at a minimum if
you're a parent like me with young kids
get your kids the hell out of this
system before your kids are destroyed by
it because they will be all right moving
on let's check in with some some news
here are 5 headlines worth knowing about
it number one Pope Francis yesterday
suggested during his general audience in
st. Peter's Square that we give up
trolling for Lent so if you're thinking
of you know if you haven't thought of
somebody to give up for Lent yet he said
that that now would be a good time to
give up trolling the Internet hello
here's the thing I you know I believe in
making sacrifices for Lent I think it's
a good practice certainly but some
sacrifices are just too much you have to
be realistic and if we give up trolling
what exactly are we supposed to do with
our time now you tell people not to
troll next thing you know everyone's
doing heroin because that those are
really the only two options that I can
think of by the way speaking of the Pope
as a Catholic I am pleading with the
Pope during this time of the coronavirus
to finally get rid of the sign of peace
during Mass now if you're not a Catholic
maybe you're not familiar that's the
part of the service about 2/3 of the way
through we're randomly the congregants
are required to exchange awkward and
perfunctory greetings with the people
around them so we take a break from from
the sacred moment take a break in the
middle of the service to exchange forced
pleasantries with our neighbors
immediately around us which which of
course makes no sense it's a very silly
and pointless ritual in my view and also
a great way to spread illness so maybe
with the you know possibility of a
pandemic this would be a good catalyst
for getting rid of that and
if you got to do it look you go to there
are many other churches you go to
Protestant churches many times and I've
been to plenty of plenty of those
churches in many cases there they'll do
a greeting type of thing before the
service starts now okay that can make
sense why are we doing it in the middle
randomly it makes no sense
number two Donald Trump is speaking the
coronavirus held a press conference with
Mike Pence in the CDC last night to talk
about the virus and president Trump was
taking an approach of essentially
downplaying it this is a little bit of
what he had to say because of all we've
done the risk to the American people
remains very low we have the greatest
experts in the war really in the world
right here the people that are called
upon by other countries when things like
this happen we were ready to adapt and
we're ready to do whatever we have to as
the disease spreads if it spreads as
most of you know the the level that
we've had in our country is very low and
those people are getting better or we
think that in almost all cases they're
the better are getting we have a total
of 15 we took in some from Japan you
heard about that because they're
American citizens and they're in
quarantine and they're getting better
too but we felt we had an obligation to
do that it could have been as many as 42
and we found that we were it was just an
obligation we felt that we had we could
have left them and that would have been
very bad very bad I think American
people
honestly act I can't quite figure this
out because it seems to me that the
corona virus is a perfect example of why
we need strong borders why I need to
control who comes in here in fact we'll
talk more about this in a minute when
we're canceling Elizabeth Warren so it's
it's it's something that that touches on
that it also touches on the needs
not be so reliant on foreign foreign
manufacturing because if there's a
pandemic and major disruptions and we're
reliant on China for all of our goods
that's a problem so that would be an
angle a perfect angle for President
Trump to take on this given that those
are two issues that he's talking about
all the time
and Steady's go on the angle of saying
that you know this is no big deal don't
worry about it I understand not wanting
to foment a panic I'm all about that you
know I also believe there's no reason to
panic we should be panicking but we you
you don't want to err on the side of
appearing lackadaisical and unconcerned
number three related to the previous odd
item Trump put Mike Pence in charge of
heading up the coronavirus response and
this move has provoked the expected
reaction here's what a Aussie had to say
she tweeted Mike Pence literally does
not believe in science it is utterly
irresponsible to put him in charge of us
coronavirus response as the world sits
on the cusp of a pandemic this decision
could cost people their lives
Pence's past decisions already have
speaking of science of not believing in
science alexandria just a quick question
quick science question you know since
you say he denies science and you
believe in science um it's a quick
science question can men get pregnant I
mean if someone who believes in science
I'd be interested to hear your answer on
that number four the house yesterday
voted 410 to four to pass a bill making
lynching a federal hate crime now of
course it was already illegal everywhere
in the country to lynch somebody if you
lynched someone prior to this bill even
if you had lynched someone anywhere
you'd be going to jail for probably the
rest of your life if not facing the
death penalty as you would deserve so
this bill doesn't make lynching illegal
but it does make it a federal crime
which means that rather arbitrarily this
one particular method of murder will be
a federal matter whereas other methods
are not so if you for example are trying
to decide how to kill somebody and you
decide okay I'm gonna
stab them or beat them to death or shoot
them well the feds have no interest in
that
if you Lynch them okay now the feds are
interested does that actually make sense
the person is just as dead either way
does it make sense to arbitrarily say
okay with this kind of murder that's but
this over here no no it doesn't make any
sense but then the whole category of
hate crime is itself absurd and also
makes no sense the hate crime
designation does two things number one
it puts the government in the position
of trying to read the mind of a criminal
the government determines whether that
person was hateful whether they had hate
in their heart when they committed the
crime which of course is actually
impossible to determine because you
can't read somebody's mind and then
number two the the hate crime
designation declares that crimes that
are motivated by hatred are somehow
automatically worse than crimes
motivated by other things but why would
that be the case you know a person may
murder out of hatred or they may do it
out of jealousy or anger or greed or
indifference are those other variants of
murder not as bad somehow I don't see
why that would be the case take on one
hand a man who kills another man because
he wants to steal his wallet and then on
and then and then consider a man who
kills another man because he hates him
for his race with color of his skin is
the second man worse than the first is
he more dangerous no on both counts I
would say no I don't thinks I think
they're equally evil and they're equally
as dangerous and the victim again is
just as dead in both cases and while in
the second case the victim is dead
because of the color of their skin in
the first he's dead because the killer
valued the $25 in his wallet more than
his own life is that better
how so why would it be
you can't say that hate crimes terrorize
communities in special ways which which
justify the federal involvement I mean
they do terrorize communities but
communities are also terrorized by
criminals who murder for money
many communities all over the country
live in fear over people like that and
you can't say that hate crimes inspire
others in a special way they that is
inspire copycats and so maybe you would
say well they inspire copycats and
that's why you need the feds involved
they might inspire copycats but again
other kinds of murder also do that
somebody pointed out yesterday we were
talking about this someone pointed out
compare the Columbine kids the Columbine
killers to Dylan roof now the latter was
a hate crime the former was not which
one of those do you think inspired more
copycats I think very clearly the
Columbine killers did they inspired a
whole generation of school shooters
wasn't a hate crime though you know what
they were doing they were doing it was
just a crime of indifference and a crime
of a sort of general disdain for the
human race I don't see why that should
be treated with less seriousness then we
treat a crime motivated by hatred all
right
well usually I do five but I guess
that's all I had I had four headlines
now um before we move on to canceling
somebody wanted to give a shout out to
all of our daily wired members you guys
are the ones who keep us in business we
love making content that matters and
while we're on the frontlines of the
culture war we can't do it without your
support if you're still skeptical about
joining the daily wire you're not sure
if you want to spend the money a
reader's pass is a great way to start a
readers pass will enable news junkies to
read all of our articles ads free
including op-eds from ben shapiro which
are exclusive to daily watch our members
you can't get them anywhere else you get
the upgraded experience in-depth
analysis from our editor-in-chief you
also get access to our mobile app which
has really become popular with all of
our members and you can read all of our
stories in mobile you don't have the ads
you can receive push notifications all
of these bells and whistles come with it
the membership tier is already a bargain
at $3 a month but right now for a
limited time we're offering that deal
for $0.99 that's mobile ad free to all
of our daily wire
News exclusive op eds from ben shapiro
breaking news updates
everything we've just talked about all
for the low price of 99 cents so give it
a shot it's worth it now time for your
daily cancellation and today I'm very
excited to be canceling Elizabeth Warren
of course there's a whole buffet of
reasons there's a cornucopia of
cancelable things that she has done and
said when it comes to Elizabeth Warren
but here's here's the latest I want to
talk to you about about this because
just tonight the the president president
from detailed the administration's
response to the spread of the corona
virus and I want to tell you what it
includes it includes stopping non-us
citizens from coming to the u.s. from
China screening people coming into the
country from infected areas quarantine
Eno's infected and developing a vaccine
do you think that response is sufficient
senator no but but let's start because
this really is serious and we have a lot
to talk about here we know that with any
virus that develops the most vulnerable
will be our children seniors people with
compromised immune systems or undergoing
treatment so this one this one is tough
so the way I think about this is first
we think about allocation kind of kind
of our overall approach I'm gonna be
introducing a plan tomorrow to take
every dime that the president is now
spending on his racist wall at our
southern border and divert it to work on
the corona virus
okay a few problems here a few things
first of all a wall cannot be racist we
get that clear walls are physical
objects they are barriers they are not
racist
they can't be because their walls the
walls in this room that I'm sitting in
right now they have really no feelings
no prejudice they have no opinion of
anyone's race they they they I've never
read met a racist wall in my life I've
never met a sexist wall a homophobic
wall I haven't met a few walls that
frankly were a bit transphobic so I
think transphobia can be a problem in
the wall community but other than that I
don't think it's something we have to
worry about second thing more
importantly perhaps we're talking about
a pandemic okay we're talking about a
disease that potentially could sweep
through the world across the globe like
a forest fire worst-case scenario of
course and your solution is your
solution is to make our borders more
porous that's your solution that's the
way you address a pandemic your way to
meet the pandemic head-on is to not
enforce our borders open borders so your
first thought when you hear Oh pandemic
well okay we got to open up the borders
that's the first thing we have to do
that's like saying your plan for
combating obesity is to give out Arby's
coupons it really makes no sense
now of course this is what I was saying
before and this this should be Trump's
messaging and he should be damned happy
by the way that I'm not canceling him
right now for not having this messaging
but the message is this is why we need
to be able to control who comes into the
country it's precisely why so Warren's
position here is incoherent reckless
dangerous stupid and she's cancelled
she's cancelled times 10 times infinity
as my kids would say all right let's
move on quickly
before we wrap things up to some emails
bat wall show at gmail.com Matt well
show at gmail.com is email address this
is from Maria says esteemed mr. Walsh I
would like to thank you profusely for
right
incredible thought-provoking genuine
book which is the Church of cowards
right here
forget Shakespeare this needs to be
required reading for all the West also I
must say your book came at the most
opportune time I'm currently a high
school student and not only was your
book the reason I didn't pay attention
all day today but much let's do my
homework but more importantly a book is
immensely beneficial in the writing of
my argument as to whether America can
truly claim to be a Christian nation and
it proved as an instrumental source for
the sermon I will soon give to my youth
group God is not convenient fitting your
faith into your lifestyle versus making
faith a lifestyle not only was your book
constructed but also hilarious although
honestly considering you wrote it I
don't know why I'm surprised I know that
the appreciation of a teenager isn't
much but for what it counts I think it
be you did an absolutely phenomenal job
this book stated what we all need to
hear the unpopular truth god bless you
and your family well Maria thank you for
that and your of course your check will
soon be in the mail you did your part
thank you from let's see her from Ryan
says I'd like to hear your response to
this counterpoint you said a bachelor's
degree only tells that the person could
pay for college or was willing to take
out a loan seldom is the situation such
that you only know their level of degree
though generally on a resume you know
their major their GPA and of course the
school if you know someone had a
marketing degree from Yale and a 4.0 are
you really willing to say you still know
nothing about them aside from the fact
they have a degree well Ryan of course a
4.0 GPA and a marketing degree from one
of the top schools in the world would
tell would tell you something as an
employer of course but those are
additional bits of information my point
was that the simple fact that a person
has a degree that fact alone just that
they have a degree tells me nothing
tells me it tells me absolutely nothing
about the person so if you tell me that
Bob Smith has a college degree
that's all you tell me I know nothing
about Bob Smith it could be dumb it
could be smart could be lazy could be
hardworking he could be anything I don't
know anything about him just by the fact
that he has a college degree and this is
why a college degree in and of
self shouldn't be a prerequisite for
many of these jobs because instead the
individual merits and experience of the
of the individual applicants should be
what we consider so imagine that
revolutionary idea
someone's applying for a job why don't
you look at them specifically and see
what they bring to the table now if you
consider Bob Smith's individual merits
and experiences okay you might discover
that he has a college degree he has a
4.0 all that other stuff and obviously
now you know you have on your hands a
very promising candidate for pretty much
any entry-level job anywhere but if
you're willing to look at the specifics
of Bob then if you've got Jim over here
who has no college degree why why don't
you look at his specifics because what
if Jim has no degree but he's 23 he's
been working at the same retailer since
he was 18
started as a part-time cashier now he's
an assistant store manager he's been
climbing up the you know up the ladder
of success maybe being promoted what
does that tell you about him
tells you he's a hard worker he has
management experience he's reliable it
can work with people he has at least
some skills and sales probably it tells
you many things about it and Jim too
would be a very promising candidate for
an entry-level position at pretty much
any company but with the way things work
now
Jim's resume goes directly in the trash
just because he doesn't have that piece
of paper even though he has all that
experience and all of that skill it goes
right in the trash even though he would
probably be a better candidate for the
job than 90% of the college the the you
know the college graduates who are
coming in the door for interviews it
just doesn't make any sense
finally from Josh says Matt on your show
you argued that we should lay some of
the blame for student debt at the feet
of universities who charge a fortune in
tuition because they can and employers
who require degrees for no reason other
than what you term laziness a bit of
history and economics show why both of
these are bad arguments historically
these practices by universities and
employers are the result of increasing
demand for an acquisition of college
degrees they're the result of their was
the result rather than the cause of the
problem
economics explains the phenomenon in
both cases the first principle is simply
supply and demand a corollary of this
principle is that price is that as that
bottom a mechanism by which goods are
rationed among all possible buyers so
universities charge more because there
are more dollars chasing fewer degrees
and there has to be some method of
reaching an equilibrium where the number
of buyers matches the number of things
to be bought so in reality universities
are just responding to market forces the
only reason prices are so high is that
ultimately the government has made it
unnaturally easy to get funding for
college this artificially increasing
demand which in turn drives up the price
in the case of employers the phenomenon
is similar except that the degree is the
price of getting the job you say this is
due to laziness but I think this is an
unwarranted assumption on your part true
a person with no degree but some work
experience might be a better fit but not
necessarily thus employers still have to
consider all applicants and narrowing
the pool by increasing the requirements
is not laziness but rather a cost-saving
measure the man-hours required to sort
through a list of applicants represent
an opportunity cost to the employer
which it's perfectly reasonable to try
to avoid I think you're also ignoring
the fact that many employers have
alternate requirements such as a possess
a degree or B have a certain amount of
experience furthermore I'm sure that in
most cases even if an applicant lacks a
degree he could still potentially get
the job if he can show that he has a
history of relevant experience that
would be worth more than degree okay
well Josh I think all you've done here
is explain why universities and
companies can get away with doing what
they're doing it doesn't prove that it
must be this way that they must do it
this way the cost of a degree has risen
by 100 percent 100 percent since I was
born in 1986 you know the average cost
of a degree
tuition rates are increasing eight times
faster than wages this is exorbitant
grotesque obviously the degree is is
worth at this point a fraction of what
it costs to obtain and almost nobody who
goes in walks in the door of a college
can actually afford the degree that
they're getting now you say that market
forces explain it yes they explain how
the universities are able to get away
with bilking people like this but it
doesn't explain why they need to or have
to I get that they can I understand that
they don't have to though they don't
need to do this they could charge half
of what they charge they could charge a
quarter of what they charge they could
do that there's no reason why they can't
now you say this is a way of rationing
the goods but as you point out yourself
the government has made it so that they
can charge whatever they want because
the loans are dished out like candy so
this isn't really a way of rationing
anything this is just a way for the
universities to take advantage of the
situation I don't see it as rationing
everybody gets a degree it's just that
they're charged a lot more they have to
pay a lot more in the end how was that
rationing also there are other ways of
rationing the degrees there are other
barriers of entry grade point average
exams test scores so on and so forth
it's not as though you know if tuition
was cheaper the universities would have
to throw up in their doors and any old
person can wander in they could still
control who they give admittance to but
they could do it based on something
other than the person's willingness to
plunge themselves into three decades of
crushing debt that's my point
as for employers you say that narrowing
the pool by disqualifying non college
grads is a cost-saving measure well even
if that's true I would say that not all
cost-saving measures are automatically
right or good you know and and this is
one that isn't but it's actually not a
cost-saving measure because you're
ruling out many candidates who could
potentially be better more effective
more reliable employees you're limiting
at
the very start your pool of candidates
only to those who are likely to have
very little real-world work experience
because they've been in college this
whole time so you're limiting yourself
only to them which means that they're
probably going to need more training in
the end and maybe less reliable in a
working environment and all of that will
cost you money in the long run so no I
don't think it actually is a cost-saving
measure III think if they if they took a
more hands-on approach to their own
hiring practices and they were really
willing to actually assess the merits of
the people like I'm in yes it may may be
a little bit more effort in the short
run but I think in the long run you save
you save money why don't they do it well
I'm sorry go back to laziness I think
it's just it's just easier to do it this
way it's also just what everybody does
and so you figure if you're a company
this is what people do and so this is
how it is and so this is what I'm gonna
do
it's a lack of imagination also and also
I think there's an element of many of
these employers the people that are in
these HR departments and so on they all
have college degrees and so I think
there's there's a little bit of a
snobbery to it
and and also I think they you know they
don't want to start if all these
employers with college degrees start
hiring people without college degrees
now they've devalued their own college
degree and they don't want to do that so
there's selfishness too so I think it's
snobbishness I think it's selfishness I
think it's laziness think it's a lack of
imagination in in so many cases and that
is why we have 1.5 trillion dollars in
debt
all right but thank you for that
counter-argument very very interesting
arguments put forward we'll leave it
there thank somebody for watching thanks
for listening
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 coronavirus reaches the u.s.
president Trump is playing it down
Democrats are playing it up and we don't
know whether we're all gonna die or
whether this is a big nothing we will
examine the cause of the mass media
generated hysteria then speaking of not
knowing whether or not you're live and
dead Joe Biden gets some very good news
from a poll in South Carolina two
different kinds of Republicans are going
to be voting for Bernie Sanders and
finally the mailbag check it out on the
Michael dole show